[MUSIC PLAYING]
PATRICK LECUYER:
Hi, I'm Patrick,
and I help customers in Montreal
learn about Google Cloud.
I'm really excited to see
the launch of our newest
region in Montreal.
This makes us the
15th GCP region
and means better
performance, lower latency,
and more flexibility
for local customers.
With the opening
of this new region,
Google Cloud Platform
products are now offered
and hosted from Montreal.
This new region has
everything that you
need to build and scale.
Our services include
compute, big data, storage,
and networking.
Let's check out the demo.
So from the main Google
Cloud Platform dashboard,
we'll go down the product
list and choose Storage.
From Storage, we have the
option of creating a new bucket.
We will create a new bucket.
We'll call that bucket
our first-canadian-bucket.
We want that bucket to
be regional storage,
because we want the data to stay
within the new Montreal region.
We'll scroll down
our list of regions
and choose
northamerica-northeast1,
which is the name of the
new Montreal-based region.
We'll click to create
that new bucket.
I now have a bucket hosted
within our Montreal region.
I just need to choose my file.
I'll upload it to the bucket.
And here we are.
We have one file stored in
our new Montreal-based region
northamerica-northeast1.
It's as easy as that.
We've opened this
region in Montreal
because of the rising
demand for cloud services.
Customers, such as Ubisoft,
Geotab, and Imagia,
just to name a few, have
leapt onto the cloud.
As part of the Hieroglyphics
Initiative research project,
video game maker Ubisoft is
using Google Cloud Storage
to sort pictures and data of
ancient Egyptian hieroglyphs.
They use Compute Engine and ML
Engine to process and classify
that data with the goal of
accelerating our understanding
of this ancient language.
The new Montreal region means
more speed and availability
for Canadian customers.
Here at Google,
we're here to help
you scale your business
the Google Cloud way.
Contact to us.